les débats se poursuivent à l'assemblée
nationale et pour protester contre cette
réforme
une marche de 8 jours a été organisé et
elle est arrivée aujourd'hui à paris des
membres de la société civile des
syndicats à des élus la france insoumise
ont quitté laval en mayenne lundi
dernier et il s'apprête à rejoindre
l'assemblée nationale les protestataires
qui dénoncent le possible recours aux 49
3 on écoute le leader de la france
insoumise clairement il vaut mieux
qu'ils réfléchissent à ce qu'ils font
parce que moi je reçois beaucoup de
messages
je n'imaginais pas que ça aurait un
impact pareil sur la sensibilité du
public beaucoup de gens sont ont compris
qu'il y avait le risque du 49-3 il ya
déjà des consignes de rassemblement
autour de l'assemblée si le 49 3 et
décidez donc je pense qu'il ya où il ya
de l'émotion dans le pays et qu'ils
doivent le savoir auprès de maquereaux
et d'edouard philippe ils doivent se
demander alors ce matin nous a fait un
petit numéro à la conférence des
présidents le président de l'assemblée
nous a dit attacher de prévoir vos
procuration pour les deux tours des
élections municipales parce que vous
serez dans l'hémicycle
ça sent la ruse